INTRO:
Usually, the richer someone gets the more
conservative they are with their investments.
This makes sense as the focus generally shifts
from wealth growth to wealth preservation
with growing riches.
Even some of the richest people in the world
who took massive risks to get to where they
are have grown more conservative with time.
Bill Gates, for example, owned 45% of Microsoft
when they went public in 1986.
But since then, he’s basically sold all
his as he owns just 1.3% of Microsoft today.
Now, Bill is still worth $128 billion, so
I think it worked out alright.
But if he had just held onto his initial stake,
he’d be worth over a trillion dollars.
Similarly, Warren Buffett was famous for beating
the S&P 500 for decades.
But today, he’s holding $150 billion worth
of cash.
So, clearly, even the richest people in the
world have gotten more conservative with time.
One billionaire who never toned it down though
was Bill Hwang.
With time, he placed riskier and risker bets
which initially paid off growing his fortune
hundreds of fold.
But like with all gamblers, when you bet it
all, it just takes one bad bet to wipe you
out.
And that’s exactly what happened last year
when Bill lost $20 billion in 2 days.
So, here’s the story of Bill Hwang and how
he made and lost billions in record time.
BILL HWANG:
Taking a look back, Bill’s story circles
back to South Korea to the year 1964.
Like many immigrant stories, Bill’s origins
were rather grim.
Bill says that his parents struggled to make
ends meet and that he had to pick up many
part-time jobs to help them out.
Despite their bleak situation, the family
never lost hope.
They were strong Christians and believed that
one way or another, things would eventually
work out.
As Bill reached his teenage years, it seemed
like their wishes were coming true as things
were finally starting to get better.
The family was able to immigrate to Las Vegas
and Bill’s father got a job as a pastor.
Unfortunately, Bill basically knew no English
which made it extremely difficult for him
to make friends, excel in school, or get a
job.
But with persistence, Bill was able to score
a nightshift at a Mcdonald’s, and Bill says
that this is where he learned to speak English.
Just as things were starting to pick up though,
Bill’s father died.
This shattered the family’s morale and they
would relocate to Los Angeles.
Despite the hardships, Bill knew that with
his father gone, he was truly on his own.
So, he put his head down and got to work.
Bill eventually secured a spot at UCLA and
majored in economics, and after his bachelor’s,
Bill turned around and got an MBA from Carnegie
Mellon University.
Despite this strong educational background,
Bill struggled to score a high paying job
out of college.
And he ended up working as a low-level salesman
and Hyundai securities.
Note that this was not at Hyundai motors,
so Bill was not a car salesman.
Rather he was a securities broker or basically
a stock salesman.
These guys aren’t nearly as common today
due to the rise of online brokerages that
are intuitive and simple to use.
But back in the day, securities brokers would
call up a bunch of people and try to convince
them to buy a particular stock or bond.
This job provided Bill with a comfortable
life, but given that he was still working
here when was 33 years old, it seemed like
Bill would never achieve much more than mediocrity
career-wise.
That was until he caught the eye of Julian
Robertson.
Julian was the founder of the hedge fund Tiger
Management Corporation.
By this point, Tiger Management was already
managing billions, and they were one of the
fastest-growing hedge funds in the world.
But like Bill, Julian had humble roots and
was initially a stockbroker himself.
Julian felt that he could see his younger
self within Bill, so he offered Bill a golden
ticket.
TIGER CUB:
Julian offered Bill a job as a financial analyst
at Tiger Management, and Bill of course took
the job.
Bill didn’t just want to be another financial
analyst though, he wanted to offer something
unique to the fund.
So, he proposed the idea of expanding Tiger
Management into Asian investments.
While Bill had assimilated quite well into
American culture, he never let go of his Asian
culture either.
Bill felt that he had a unique perspective
on Asian companies and that he was the guy
for Asian investments.
Julian gave him a shot, and it quickly became
clear that Bill wasn’t bluffing.
He hit home run after home run investing in
dot-com favorites like SK Telecom.
Amongst his peers, Bill became known as “the
Michael Jordan of Asian Investing”.
With the help of Bill, Tiger Management over
doubled their assets between 1997 and 1998
from $10.5 billion to $22 billion.
This made Tiger Management the second-largest
hedge fund in the world.
But it wasn’t all sunshines and rainbows.
To achieve these mad returns, Bill was investing
in some of the most speculative names of the
Dotcom bubble.
Many of his picks would crash 80 to 90% in
the early 2000s and they haven’t moved since.
But, fortunately for Bill, he would never
have to experience this downfall as Julian
would soon shut down Tiger management.
You see, Tiger had made an investment in US
Airways that wasn’t doing so well.
Aside from this, Julian was already in his
60s, he was already a multi-billionaire, and
he could sense the stock market was getting
superheated.
So, he decided that he didn’t want to push
his luck.
In March of 2000, Julian went ahead and sold
most of his stocks, shut down Tiger Management,
and distributed all remaining profits to investors.
Considering that March 24, 2000, was literally
the peak of the Dotcom bubble, you could say
this was spectacular timing.
Or maybe, Julian’s selling was the catalyst
that turned the tide.
Who knows?
But either way, shutting down Tiger Management
was a great call for Julian.
Now, we should note that Julian ended bag
holding US Airways to 0 as the company ended
up going bankrupt.
Nonetheless, by shutting down Tiger in 2000,
Julian significantly reduced his losses and
made it out quite well.
Too bad, these skills didn’t rub off on
Bill.
Anyway, while Julian was done with running
his own hedge fund, he wasn’t completely
done with the hedge fund space quite yet.
He was well aware that by shutting down Tiger,
he put 97 bright investors out of a job.
So, Julian launched a seed funding program
that gave his former employees capital to
start their own hedge funds.
By the end of the decade, Julian helped launch
38 different hedge funds which are often referred
to as Tiger Cubs.
As you would guess, Bill used this opportunity
to launch his own hedge fund called Tiger
Asia.
BANNED:
From the very beginning, Bill ran Tiger Asia
on the edge.
Most of his positions were outsized leveraged
bets that could go really well or really bad.
For the first couple of years, Tiger Asia
posted stellar numbers as the market recovered
from the dot-com crash.
By 2007, Bill boasted a nutty 40% annualized
return managing a total of $8 billion.
But, when you’re constantly playing with
fire, it’s only a matter of time until you
get burned.
And Bill’s first burn came in late 2008
during the height of the great recession.
Considering the timing, you would think that
Bill got burned by an outsized bullish bet
which would actually be quite understandable.
But ironically, Bill actually got destroyed
by a short position.
If you’re not familiar with shorting, it’s
basically the opposite of regular stock investing.
You make money when the stock goes down and
you lose money when the stock goes up.
Anyway, considering the recession, Bill thought
that it would be a great idea to short Volkswagen.
In theory, he should’ve been right, but
Porsche’s rapidly growing stake in Volkswagen
set off an insane short squeeze.
And if you thought the Gamestop short squeeze
was nuts, this was on another level.
The percentage gains weren’t as much as
Gamestop as Volkswagen only grew 4 to 5x from
$200 to nearly $1000.
But given that Volkswagen wasn’t initially
a penny stock, the short squeeze actually
made Volkswagen the biggest company in the
world momentarily.
This caused Tiger Asia to lose 23% of their
entire portfolio, and as you would guess,
investors weren’t happy.
They were furious that Bill was even involved
with Volkswagen.
The hedge fund was called Tiger Asia and it
was supposed to be focused on Asian investments.
Many investors pulled their money out of Tiger
Asia after the fiasco, but Bill did recover.
His colleagues say that he learned from this
mistake and that ever since this experience,
he opted to buy into heavily shorted stocks
as opposed to just shorting them as well.
Over the next couple of years, Bill recovered
from his mistake, but unfortunately, his next
mistake would be unsalvageable.
In 2012, Tiger Asia would get convicted of
insider trading.
Bill was fined $44 million and he was permanently
banned from managing other people’s money.
With Bill out of the hedge fund scene, you
would think that this was the end of Bill’s
journey.
But this was just the beginning of Archegos.
ARCHEGOS:
Since Bill could no longer manage outside
money, he decided to manage his own fund.
He had already made hundreds of millions during
his time in Wall Street, so he didn’t need
outside money.
If Bill just went ahead and invested his own
money, it wouldn’t have been that bad, but
he wasn’t happy with just making ordinary
returns.
Bill wanted extraordinary returns, so he turned
to his favorite strategy: leveraged trading.
Bill went ahead and borrowed money from banks
in order to fund his trading.
Now, this itself is extremely dangerous, but
Bill would take it to the next level.
You see, banks aren’t stupid enough to loan
Bill hundreds of millions and eventually billions
to go gamble in the stock market.
Banks want to ensure that there’s very little
risk of losing their own capital, so they
use collateral and margin calls.
For example, let’s say that you wanted to
buy $200 worth of Apple shares but you only
have $100.
Chase will happily loan you the other $100
if you put up your $100 worth of Apple shares
as collateral.
This way, they have quite a bit of leeway.
Apple stock would have to crash 50% for the
total position to be worth less than $100,
and the second that Apple does reach -50%,
Chase will sell your stock and get their money
back.
On the other hand, if the stock skyrockets,
they’re happy to just collect interest and
go on with their day.
But what if you use the same $100 as collateral
with many different lenders.
Now, as a retail investor, banks will make
sure you don’t do this as they don’t really
trust you.
But with someone like Bill, they were much
looser with their restrictions which allowed
Bill to take on 3 to 1, 5 to 1, and even 8
to 1 leverage.
Bill used this strategy to 100x his portfolio
from $200 million to $20 billion, and no one
noticed a thing.
You see, as long as your positions are playing
out, there’s no problem with leverage.
It’s only when your positions go south that
you get wiped out.
By 2021, Bill’s personal net worth stood
at $20 billion, but he was trading with $100
billion meaning that he had $80 billion worth
of debt spread across multiple banks.
This means that if Bill’s positions dipped
just 20%, he would have a negative net worth
and he should be margin called.
But, banks didn’t know this.
They thought they had 40 or 50% worth of leeway
and this became painfully evident when one
of Bill’s biggest positions crumbled.
In March of 2021, ViacomCBS announced that
they would do a share offering which caused
the stock to tumble over 50% within a week.
Given that this was one of Archegos’ biggest
positions, banks started to margin call Bill
and this is when they realized they were screwed.
Not only had Bill blown away his entire net
worth, but he had also caused banks including
Morgan Stanley, Goldman Sachs, Credit Suisse,
and Nomura to incur $10 billion worth of losses.
And with that Archegos filed for bankruptcy.
THE AFTERMATH:
At the end of the day, no one really cared
about the banks losing money as it was due
to their own lack of due diligence.
But, many were sad that Bill lost all his
money.
You see, while Bill definitely had a gambling
problem, he was putting his winnings to good
use.
He wasn’t blowing it on yachts and jets.
Instead, he lived an extremely modest life
and donated a total of $590 million to churches,
schools, and charities.
And Bill has repeatedly iterated that his
greatest love in life is god and that the
primary reason he was chasing money was so
that he could donate it.
So, it’s really quite a shame that things
have to come to this, but he should’ve thought
about that before he was gambled with $100
billion.
But that’s just what I think.
Do you guys think Bill has had a net positive
or net negative impact on the world?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you respect Bill’s
balls of steel.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in different
languages and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered.